let me bring in Mike Florio from pro
football talk like if you're 35 and you
can win a championship in any sport you
wanted or you can have a child yours
you're single at the time but you can
have a child but that's I don't have
other children no that's the only year
you can have a child the only year
you're gonna win a championship what
would you go in a championship you never
have a child no I take a child a million
times over a million times over what if
you're 20 but it doesn't if you can
never have a check giving up your
ability to ever have a child for a
championship a million times over you
take the child yeah but it's time I
don't know 20 you don't have any
perspective you're just going I mean who
wants a child at 20 when you can have a
championship in 20 well right but I'd
like to think because I'll admit that I
had no perspective at age 20 and I still
struggle to have perspective today but
if someone had told me this is your only
chance you're never going to have a
child if you don't have one now speak
now forever hold your peace I'd like to
think that enough of my soul would have
flickered through in that moment to say
take the child you wouldn't fit into
this room well I mean it's easy for
everyone who has children to say that
they take the championship and I'm sure
that there are days when my son was much
younger I would have gladly taken the
championship be 20 now no 19 I want to
wish his life away 19 now so it's far
less maintenance for me but uh yeah
without question you take the child
right now how do we do it a champion
take a championship yeah I'm the
champion there's the trophy then what do
you do with your life is it is the
trophy going to take care of you when
you're old and need to be taken care of
I mean that's not why you have kids but
it's just one of the examples one of the
benefits that having a family I guess
you're giving way too much thought to
this yeah I'm well I what you ask me
question I answer and you gave way too
much thought to JJ Watt last night what
happened all of a sudden somebody goes
all they're playing the feud it'sit's
Florio against JJ Watt is tight uh men's
soccer kit that he had on why did it
bother you I i well I felt like that was
the best possible way to send off Skip
Bayless from his time at the mothership
right I look here's the thing and
there's more
just what JJ Watt did last night he has
a habit of doing things to attract
attention to himself and then getting
frustrated when the things he does to
clearly attract attention to himself
attract attention to himself I have no
problem with someone being a Kardashian
butt he wants to in the same breath say
why are you looking at me Here I am
wearing a shirt that is 10 sizes too
small with autographs all over it why is
anybody reacting to this even though i
have sent this picture out to two
million people who follow me on twitter
and that's been retweeted and discussed
please don't talk about me as I share my
life with anyone and everyone who
happens to pay attention to it that's a
disconnected I can't reconcile and he
has talked about it in the past and he
doesn't get it and he's closer to 20
than 50 and I think he doesn't have the
benefit of perspective he just doesn't
understand you can't seek attention and
act like you don't want attention and
expect everyone to say okay that's
perfectly fine what was JJ's response
while his response was like don't know
how Twitter works if you don't like what
I'm doing don't follow me and my
response is don't you know how Twitter
works you put it out there unless you've
got a private account that no one can
see unless they're pre-approved to
follow you you may as well be taking an
ad out in the paper because anyone with
a Twitter account can see it and I don't
follow him but I follow the Texans and
they retweeted it that's how Twitter
works so this this notion of if you
don't like it don't look it's it's kind
of adolescent and it's just it's not
logical uh yes hey everybody look at me
but if you don't like it look away
that's basically what he's saying this
is what I think you need to do I think
you need to get a really really tight
shirt today and maybe while blogging on
ProFootballTalk and then just tweet that
out and make sure JJ Watt season yeah
I'm sure that would go over very well
I'm sure everybody would love that I'm
sure everybody would get the joke too
but you can just say that you're sending
this out to JJ Watt as a response just
to look I am willing to concede freely
the JJ Watt look a heck of a lot better
in an extra
medium shirt than I would let's try at
that point i don't know let's try Mike I
think you should you I think you're
selling yourself short I don't know I
may have to i may have to drink some of
that woodford you gave me at Christmas
time to make it happen have you tapped
into that yet all right yeah but only at
this special occasion ok the top shelf
stops okay i am dr. keep certain up
there Mike now it's good stuff thank you
buddy all right but that's so Mike
Florio ProFootballTalk he went after JJ
Watt the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience